doch machen wir jetzt noch meine wurst
kameras den hallo ich meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
runde körper beziehungsweise käufer bzw
8 in die kurve zusammen mit den
eu-staaten einmal das spiel
ich hoffe es wird witzig mein lieber
freund wäre nicht mehr
den nimmt nicht mit auf aber dennoch
einfach dabei und wir wollten endlich
über etwas reden du weißt wie es geht
also erstmal ganz klar die zuschauer es
gibt hier zwei filme dinner ist den er
ist der grüne wurde es gibt items die
man einsammeln kann eine richtige
verzaubert ich glaube schon scheiße ich
weiß nicht oder du bist einfach drauf
und wir müssen halt so aufpassen dass
die anderen würmer außer wir in unserer
einfachen und wenn ich selbst mich
einfach mich gestorben habe ich
gestorben
wodurch gestorben horst becker versucht
doch nix und ihr guckt ihr an wie ich
gestorben
ich wage niemand
wir wollten über etwas reden und zwar
unsere aktion bei minecraft ihrer
unserer unserer zeit der von uns aus
total legitim war nur irgendwie meinen
jetzt alle du bist jetzt ich dachte du
wirst schnell wenn ich wenn ich das
grüne einsammeln verdammen und zwar war
es von uns aus komplett legitim und geil
aber paar zuschauer müssen jetzt halt
rum hätten und beleidigen
also bei mir gegen mich und bei mir auch
manchmal gegen den weil jetzt auch
einige gegenden sind die sagen
allerdings selber eine pussy
aber der unterschied ist zwischen einer
kampfpause und in dungeons positionen
zurückhalten und zwischen eine aktion an
ich habe mich ausreden konzentriert
vielleicht gar ausgefallen und da habe
ich halt in dem moment fand ich das eine
ziemlich gute aktion dass der lokal
gesagt hatten da der regel funden hat da
mächtig ins ähnlich killer
ja ich fahre weiter irgendwie ich glaube
springt im schreiben den gewesen
da kannst du aufholen und dann ja machen
was gut deine punkte da
das ist dann in dem moment sagt
apotheken crafter und und ist damit sehr
unterscheiden zwischen sowas und
irgendwie auch für uns komplett alle
hassen oder irgendwie sowas darf das mit
einer regel ausgedacht habe aber ich
habe mich halt einfach echt so
überrascht geführt bei denen überhaupt
genau erwartet verloren
ich habe ich halt immer mehr richtig
verarscht gefühlt bei denen die ganze
meinte er sehr weg vor mir und obwohl
ich dachte die ganze zeit ich wir haben
recht die nacht erwerben rechten hat
mich dann für den angriff durch
angegriffen jetzt bin ich wieder schnell
glaube ich bin ich schnell ich das
einsammeln
ich weiß nicht ich will nicht einsammeln
ich bin mega stars macht erst dann da
und vom alter wie komisch war das denn
pankow wo ich lang gefangen weniger
krass gewesen
und da dachten wir uns wir nehmen das
jetzt ganz gut und zu zeigen dass wir
uns alles frisch ist und meine musik hat
gerade aufgehört meine auch da will ich
ihn nicht reingebracht
du bist einfach ihre rente vor
eingebracht hatten nein einfach um zu
zeigen dass wir doch alles im grünen
bereich ist und das ich führe
und das ist doch alles chili ist und
alle module ruhe und dass alle mal
chillen sollten hier am start und es da
schallt aufhört da scheint jetzt spielen
wir dann eine physische körper weiter
dass sie es doch eigentlich mal anders
oder yahoo sackt um die kurve haben es
umbenannt glaube das war so eine
amerikanische adis köpfe
sie war und dann gab es eine deutsch
nach mache dies macht den kurven dann
gab sie streiten haben sich die seiten
gegenseitig übernommen
das war stark von mir hatte das war
richtig stark aber ich habe auch erzählt
ja das stimmt das ist natürlich nacht
lang gewesen
der körper werde auf jeden fall besser
für den internationalen markt dort
erstmal sowie schülervz noch mein gott
bei mir läuft grad nicht so heftig doch
ich führe bei mir läuft doch ich denke
mir läuft nicht aber dafür viel heftiger
als bei dir ja aber nur weil ich zwei
mal prinz aus drei mach eins aus
gefahren bin einfach so bei mir mal
genau genau dann hört es wieder auf als
drittem einsehen
3 volt familie hein könnte mit milch das
wäre cool wenn wir das selbst bestimmen
könnt wenn das ausfällt aber es wäre zu
heavy war noch ineinander oder geht der
wahl dieser kurzen anfangs hielt es
nicht gut wenn ich jetzt langsam du bist
du das objekt euch das loch ja ich habe
einige konnten punkte gemacht na ja ich
hab nicht gewonnen durch eine dummheit
sondern durch meine karriere nicht auf
dich hab' wohl auch einmalig können wir
wollen uns da oben diese links gemacht
ja einer von sieben merkst du schon
verschätzt mal auf du machst dich mal
erstmals weg natürlich
also ich komm mir nicht entscheiden
richter links jetzt gewinne ich höre ich
verspreche dir
das ganze 19 punkten rangiert jetzt aber
das war ja das neueste show von mir
jetzt werde ich gefunden
pass mal auf jetzt mache mich jetzt noch
meine wurst gras der trainer wollte
krieg und das einfach gestorben
ich muss ich muss jetzt die auch noch
gewinnen dann ist matchball
ja ich gewehr 2.5 am meer das meint
jedoch dadurch nicht machen
der name selbstverständlich noch ein
spiel um und dann also wenn die letzte
winter mal noch ein spieler den er dann
noch mal gewinnt dann entstehen aber der
sieger dann aber gewinne dann ist und
ihn damit wir noch ein
entscheidungsspiel machen
orange schnell läuft bei brent bei dir
jetzt hat ihn das erst zu geworden ist
noch eine runde ist bis 11
tie break beim tennis jetzt ist ein
break bis zwölf alter es geht ja oder
nein sehen walter tie-break man muss mit
zwei punkten abstand gewinnen
das ist krass wusste aber auch nicht
dass ich habe noch eine chance den
aktivisten oder pizza da wo ich jetzt
was geschafft und dann wäre es auch beim
kreis drin gewesen
bei mir läuft schon ein bettchen lukas
die blaue macht alter statt blau gegen
statt denen das war deine chance alter
mann
das geht einfach ich das was ich mir bis
20 uhr bis 20 machen natürlich
irgendwann döner aus wenn ich in köln
oh mein gott mein gott verbunden
wir sind ein kessel dort waren das total
ausgefallen
er halte das ist meine chance das ganze
zu gewinnen ja das stimmt ich habe eine
taktik war dumm von mir ich ja mal warum
ich nach eingefahren
ich habe das erste gewonnen 10 losgeht
den erwischte bereit mir von firma her
ich brauche noch zwei minuten
das geht nicht das gewinnen bin ich der
king of körper war ja aber bild dir
nicht dass vier bar auf ein bar guck mal
ich hab ein kreis gemacht ich habe eine
formel 1 strecke gemacht mit ein paar
löcher muss man drüber jumpen muss aber
du bist in mario kart strecke ein mario
kart strecke
ich habe mir so ein spiel einfach für
die playstation gekauft als ich bisher
das spiel wird immer wenn wir irgendwie
vorträgen sind das nennt sich f1 race
stars kennt ja das kenne ich ehrlich
klar meinte der meister das ist mega
witzig das ist so wie mario kart mit
vettel und somit super mario hat ist
cooler yamaoka hat es wirklich cooler
das stimmt dann muss die rechte was
gibt's nicht für playstation
geschenketisch wir wo man sich
gegenseitig abschießen können da kann
man sich nicht abschießen
doch die standnummer zu tanzen wie kann
man das tanzen und sonja vergleich wer
weiter geradeaus fahren kann zu lenken
oh mein gott wenn du dann noch
durchgekommen wäre es geht los
schon wieder
du fährst du also um die items or um
etwas was bringt mir das bringt das du
stirbst was bringt mir das war einfach
einer fan tag dafür ist nein es direkt
gewinnen so jetzt einfach einen kreis
die ganze zeit da geht dann ich werde
das so gestorben
ich selber fordert wieder sind glück
gehabt oder besser noch gewesen ja den
hast einfach glücklich in allen spielen
außer hast wirklich die schuhe
eigentlich nicht im kampf gegen mich an
ja sonst wäre ja nicht anfeuert ich will
nur ein feuer schaden trägt ja du hast
am anfang halt neuen herzen oder so
abgezogen bekommen von mir das habe ich
in diesem hub dings nicht nur im herzen
aber 99 die inhalte als zwölfte das
lebensalter
ja ich habe das glück des todes und
danach passt ja die ganze zeit vorher
schaden bekommen
ich weiß nach hätte ich dich trotzdem
geplättet ich weiß es gar nicht ich
hatte ja immer gleichen regenbogen wie
du mit den gleichen verzauberungen ja
aber ich bin besser ja stimmt alter wie
krass das war wohl das war doch als zu
fett bin und nicht durch gepasst hätte
alter doch schon übrigens leute ich kann
nicht mit der gt aufnehmen
wie kann nicht zusammengeht er aufnehmen
warum nicht denen du hast eine
playstation hat eine xbox das geht nicht
die einzigen die playstation namen sind
simon zombie terminals play chemnitz
play und jung ich bin fett und du hast
trotzdem verpackt ich war fett und
schnell
ja es steht 5 5 ich denke mal ich führe
1000 millionen zu null
ich denke an das alter das war doch ney
kommen
ich bin nur gestorben weil ich
allerdings weil ich da auf einmal fett
wurde
tja walter dass ich das schon ich hab'
ich finde diese soundeffekt immer mega
witzig werden zwei medien zwei paint
linien fahren ineinander
naja kommt noch drei punkte ich gewinne
zehn zu sechs alter du bist du mein gott
okay dann gelächter uralter du bist du
bist einfach heftig
wer dir läuft auf jeden fall
ich wollte mich der mann gestorben
noch zwei punkte nicht das gewinnen habe
ich komplett gewonnen da er und flog
einfach raus eine magische geschichte
veni vidi vici
wenn ich das jetzt schafft er das
tie-break erstmal froh aber wenn du dort
gewinnst kommt noch eine komplette runde
alter dass es voll entscheidend gerade
die zuschauer kennt sich schon der länge
des videos erkennen wahrscheinlich ja
okay der tie-break tie-break erstmal an
spannung pur
ich schwitze hier richtig heftig eine
richtigkeit nicht versteht man nicht
nein man ja wohl verdammt gäste ins land
verdammen ihr wisst dass jahrelang so
weiter
ich höre jetzt gibt es ja bis 13 oder so
das ist folge lag bei mir die leute
richtig bei mir lukas loh connection
laser lukas lacko max koslow nächten
junisession dann bleibt nur was ich sehe
dass tochter programms aus lieber des
gefährtes gewährte aber bei direkt in
mich meine leser lag bei dir noch okay
was gut aber dafür ist das nicht gut
meist schön fände ich fand ich war auf
die ganze zeit richtig fett
ja bin ich selbstverständlich immer noch
walter ich bin so knapp an der
schildkröte vorbei nein
ok jetzt kommt noch eine
entscheidungsrunde
bist du bereit für das alles
entscheidende match ja ein bisschen vom
perfekten kreis gemacht
rudds pläne du warst einfach nur kreis
wenn du nicht weisst meinen kreis oder
wird dieser spruch du hast du nur so
halb völlig geschafft sich schnell als
alles musik richtig entspannt okay okay
okay aber nur weil fett bin
die nachgehen wie gar nichts an farben
einschenken pro weg ich hasse ich darf
man darf eigentlich nie aus zu sein in
diesem spiel
ich war gleich einig falls aber die
ganze zeit in man sieht ja fast gar
nicht gemacht
lang ich bin wieder meine ich weiß nur
dass nicht mal nein bei dem wir diese
taktik entwickelt haben die kürzen die
runde macht richtig richtig lang wieder
kam hob abschnittes experte
die puppen abweist eher darum dass
verloren
also gab ich gas bin ja heftig mag so
langsam lex nokia hoffen
leider alle oka wird mehr lang auf thema
internet und wenn man hier
ausstellungsteil im internet unter nicht
schlecht weil ich mich aber erst recht
nicht mehr den er beschließt einfach mal
so kurzfristig portal o ich sterbe
einfach einen grünstich das rote den man
auch bei chrysler ich will mit zwei
punkten abstand liegt es nun im internet
oder den ich einfach gut du bist auch
raus wir sind beide eltern hört sich so
scheiße wie komme ich als alter ohne
witzmann ich war auf einmal andersrum
ich verliere nur wegen es locken kann
doch nicht sein
ich hatte drei punkte abstand ist das
ärgerlich chips nach 2
hast du spaß was aufgefallen ich bin
falsch rum
oh mein gott alter ich war aber falsch
rufen mich habe ich gemacht was ich
damit jetzt lass mal versuchen uns nicht
zu töten okay jeder findet seinen
eigenen runden okay danach töten von dem
74 auf 7 zu kommen man bei dir läuft
okay das ist jetzt der entscheidende
kampf ist der crafter das meine ich denk
suchen der den an der ich schon ganz gut
aber jetzt nach ich war noch zwei punkte
ich gehe dann eben durch dich durch aber
nicht so lange in der 88 das hat doch
noch einen punkt von vorher das jetzt
sehr doch gleich noch ein punkt da bin
ich der achtung die kurve king werde ich
der keen werden
vielleicht nicht mehr kannst ja ich bin
der king of kain feld gut meine lieben
freunde das war's mit körper so wollt
ihr mehr davon wollt ihr das mit anderen
leuten event aber ich wollte es jetzt
einfach mal so machen mit denen kurz um
diese sache eigentlich mit dem schiff
nur mal kurz aufzuklären und sonst würde
ich sagen wir sehen uns dann in einem
anderen video wieder diener du dir aber
dass ich die letzten worte